every jab every feint and every hook
brings ten-year-old daughter closer to
achieving his dream his dream of
becoming a champion boxer he trains six
days a week it's a grueling routine but
he wouldn't miss a single day
boxing is everything to daughter do you
like it yes Beck did you win any medals
i won - is it hard or easy for you to
beat these guys easy
have you ever been beaten I always win
you've never lost I've never lost thing
is everything to coach patriotic he's
worked a miracle in the Moldovian
village of griemann coats on the border
with Ukraine his boxing school is among
the most successful in all of Europe
I would very much like to create
world-class athletes creating national
champions or participants and world and
European competitions is very satisfied
and if these athletes receive awards
then I'm overjoyed Dimitri Galligan is
the European vice champion for his
weight class to keep his weight steady
he trains in an airtight suit he has to
deliver top performance in near sonic
conditions for over an hour
Petrovic is known for his rigorous
training methods but these boys feel
honored to have him as their coach they
each have their own dreams of greatness
those dreams don't include daydreaming
duro might take time out for a game of
chess with his little sister but he's
ambitious and focused on his goals in
the ring he prefers to pit himself
against stronger boxers even if the odds
are against him I know they're bigger
and stronger and they have more practice
I want to become like them his mother is
proud of him and his determination
dildoes father used to box later like
hundreds of thousands of Moldovans he
worked abroad for years now he's
returned to his village and his roots
this is where he's got his family Pedro
and his wife Svetlana have big plans the
Town Council has given him use of an old
school building he's planning to turn it
into a boarding school a Sports Academy
of his own over here we're going to
build a multi-purpose hall 42 by 24
meters in size
it'll have viewing stands and provides
space for competitions and training for
other sports it's not yet certain where
the money for the Academy will come from
the state finances the boxing school but
Moldova is poor and struggling just to
cover daily expenses the money doesn't
really flow that's the main problem we
sign contracts and transfer money but
the money comes in very slowly because
the country's financial situation
negatively affects the boxing school as
well as soon as school's out door rule
hurries off to boxing practice he's been
at it for about a year he's interested
in soccer and astronomy but his passion
is the boxing ring
he has no less Drive and single-minded
dedication than any adult his coach has
high expectations for him Doro is a very
disciplined boy who listens boys like
him are very rare he has a gift and
comes to training and to work on it when
he sees a stronger boxer he tries to
copy him to become stronger himself
Pedro Kerouac's says that's what makes
the difference between a good boxer and
a champion maybe one day he'll have
Doros trophy to put in the case
alongside all the other medallions and
cups his boxers have won I'm a coach
with an international reputation but I
don't have the courage to leave the
village Celeste it's better for me to
stay home
for boys like daaru boxing is a world
unto itself here in the village a world
of glory that may have something to do
with the success of grim encodes boxing
school